try to survive don't go go the rest of
the way I can outsmart you right in the
balls
I had it no got it
but son and you get that dildo out from
in between my wheels I would really like
to move forward into jumping sorry all
right you could ease we're in a magic
weapon fight you really shouldn't be
watching this why do these zombies well
now that I got a jetpack out of my butt
I don't know what else I need to do in
my life because I pretty much got
everything I need it's a zone of death
you stay away from me you moosh douche
boosters whoo oh my chest
you son of [ __ ] oh you only got my
sauna not me what a dick you are I'm
sorry oh I'm on the receiving side well
I wanna see you kill yourself you dick
you're coming with me you're gonna be my
shield for the rest of the rock I'm
still alive Wow kids son of a [ __ ]
thank you son well let's see if
something happens with this ball of dead
to the point where I'm a cool to 99% I
didn't even notice that you're pulling
off my head son
you [ __ ] are looking at me a little
funny how about you back up there a bit
if I'm assuming that this is the correct
implementation of this design hope a big
rock doesn't come after me like that I'm
okay I'm ding dong why see kid we can
learn at the Science Museum a kid I'm
gonna be just
damn thing showdown oh my god are you
kidding me you son of a [ __ ] okay where
am I going what am i do wrecking ball
thanks for making it the gravity ball
seems to be spinning up now and we will
soon discover what it means to die via
gravity any minute now
well okay maybe not maybe I need to let
go here we go
kill the humans okay I get what you're
saying kill the people want me to rape
five and play their stupid game this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye